[Applaudissements]
ne pourront pas ils ne pourront rien sur
la troisième
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on a les outils qu'on voulait depuis le
début de saison donc il y a rien à dire
cette saison c'est incroyable
et on a gagné tout et je suis vraiment
très content
c'est exceptionnel il faut profiter
[Musique]
le résultat la régularité elle parle
pour elle-même
la lumière au bout d'un long tunnel le
TVB s'impose face à Chaumont en finale
du championnat de France et pourtant
rien n'était acquis après une année 2021
2022 si cruel trois finales trois
défaites en championnat en Coupe de
France et en Coupe d'Europe
[Applaudissements]
renouer avec la victoire était donc
essentielle pour le plus grand club du
volley français mais il a fallu
retourner au travail se faire mal en
attendant un nouveau printemps fatidique
rendez-vous et pris le 2 avril à la
Halle Georges Carpentier pour la finale
de la Coupe de France
face à un surprenant novice à ce stade
de la compétition Nice le TVB maths
l'insolent prétendant 3,7 à 0 et ça juge
une onzième Coupe de France
[Applaudissements]
restez le titre de champion de France
allait-il revenir au premier de la
saison régulière
un sans faute en car face à Montpellier
une demi maîtrisée contre Tourcoing
mais le TVB tombe de haut en finale
aller en Haute-Marne et reçoit une
correction infligée par Chaumont 3 7 à 0
cette défaite sème le doute quelques
heures avant un ultime défi la finale
retour une finale finalement à sens
unique 1 7 0 2 0 3 0 et la victoire
finale au Golden 7
j'ai demandé un truc à mes joueurs dans
les vestiaire rentrer tous ensemble
rentrer la tête haute rentrer la tête
haute rentrer avec un visage et si vous
croisez les visages de vos adversaires
montré tout de suite qui vous n'aimiez
pas les combats ils nous ont fait du mal
un peu au centre mais on a dominé le
service réception donc à partir de là on
était bien lancés et on a réussi à on a
réussi à gérer le match on a les quatre
saisons donc c'est parfait c'est pas un
public qu'on avait c'est un peuple
c'était énorme le peuple de la Touraine
on le rassemble souvent ici
on forceps le TVB remporte son 9e titre
de champion de France et s'offre pour la
sixième fois un doublé historique coupe
championnat une fin de saison en
apothéose
[Applaudissements]